most of us have multiple notebooks and
notes and books and things like that in
front of us can you hold up what you've
been referring to and answering
our questions
is there anything on it uh that
letterhead that says united states
senate
that's impressive
judge amy coney barrett with a blank pad
in front of her throughout a lot of
questioning from democrats and
republicans
as this hearing goes on about ready to
resume in about 11 or 12 minutes we'll
bring you back there when it does let's
bring in our panel bill bennett
former education secretary host of the
bill bennett show podcast
mar elias national political
correspondent national public radio
and guy benson political editor
townhall.com host of the guy benson show
on fox news radio
mara your thoughts on the day and the
tactics by democrats and
how judge barrett has done
judge barrett was poised and unflappable
she didn't want to answer questions
about how she might rule
or how she might approach different
issues like abortion or a contested
election
or she didn't want to weigh in on
whether the president has the
constitutional ability to delay an
election
so she parried pretty well throughout
the day
and democrats tried as hard as they
could to get her on the record
but they didn't i didn't don't think
they expected to
and in some ways this was a strange kind
of hearing because the
outcome is not in doubt at all
the republicans have the votes bill
obviously confirmed
yeah and in fact cory booker senator
cory booker
said your colleagues uh on the supreme
court um
catching himself because he was heading
that way
bill obviously justice kagan justice
sotomayor
did the same ruth bader ginsburg type
perry with
republican questioning for their
confirmation hearings
yeah and she copied that no forecast no
predictions
uh and uh you know no no no no
indications of what she's gonna
how she's gonna rule that's exactly
right very poised very impressive very
smart
uh smartest person in the room and uh
that was
that was apparent the thing that was
interesting to me is that they were
talking
past each other to some degree um the
the democrats kept holding up these
pictures of these people in terrible
circumstances sick people people in bad
shape
and saying what would you do about that
but the question isn't
whether the government or the court will
do anything about that the question
before the court
is whether the legislative remedies that
are put forward to help these people
are constitutional it's a different set
of questions the supreme court is not a
public charity
or a foundation the supreme court
decides on constitutionality
she had to keep reminding that and the
other thing which is very interesting
you know amara said it's foregone
conclusion she'll be confirmed
it's also pretty much brad a foregone
conclusion
that the affordable care act will not be
taken down as unconstitutional
severability which means
you can take the piece out that is
objectionable means
and two conservative justices have come
out in favor of that alito and kavanaugh
once you do that the rest of the act can
stand because the presumption of the
court
is that legislatures should be allowed
to do what they want to do
so this notion that if she's confirmed
she'll vote with the bad guys
the bad conservatives it's going to be
6-3
to preserve the affordable care act
anyway kind of missing the point
yeah one of the interesting question
exchanges was with amy klobuchar
about super precedent take a listen guy
is row a super precedent people use
super precedent differently
okay the way that it's used in the
scholarship and the way that i was using
it
and the article that you're reading from
was to define
cases that are so well settled that no
political actors
and no people seriously push for their
overruling as
richard fallon from harvard said roe is
not a super precedent because calls for
its overruling have never ceased but
that doesn't mean
that rose should be overruled it just
means that it doesn't fall
on the small handful of cases like
marbury versus madison and brown versus
the board that no one questions
anymore again very well briefed guy that
was about roe v
wade and whether it was a super
precedent obviously that's going to come
up again with democratic questioning
yeah she handled that challenge very
well from senator klobuchar
i think because there's so little drama
about the likely outcome here i've been
paying attention to
each side how they're using their time
particularly on the democratic side i
think they're trying to
make a few points leading up to the
election to play to their strengths in
the election
i think that senator feinstein was
pretty effective i know she's gotten
some criticism from her own side
being maybe not up to the challenge
anymore i think she did a good job
senator durbin i think did a pretty
effective job as did senator coons
other people were far less effective i
would point out
sheldon whitehouse from rhode island who
spoke for 30 straight minutes
the nominee did not say one word during
his conspiracy theory
uh senator hirono was was quite a feat
to watch as well
so it's been a bit of a mixed bag today
you know a lot of the senators started
at some point and amy klobuchar did this
that
that congress should be dealing with a
coronavirus stimulus package
not dealing with this uh i want to play
what happened on cnn a little while ago
house speaker pelosi pressed by wolf
blitzer
about why not take a deal something from
the republican so
something can get across the finish line
mar take a listen
1.8 trillion dollars is a lot of money
the american people need that money asap
because they're suffering
right now and i'm i'm not saying it's
perfect but i'm saying you don't care
how it's spent
i don't know i care of course i would
spend but i what i don't know you don't
even know how
why not why not talk to the president
personally call him up
and say mr president let's get a deal
tomorrow look
let me say this the president has sent
mr mnuchin
to negotiate that's what we've done with
other presidents this isn't unusual
it's not about me it's about millions of
americans who can't put food on the
table
who can't pay the rent and we represent
them and we
represent them and we represent these
long food lines
i know you know them
the interview went on like that kudos to
wolf for pressing on this issue mara
that is a question why not get to
something
instead of nothing yeah this is this is
pretty extraordinary you know she has
some liberal members including ro connor
who is very progressive bernie sanders
supporter
who thinks that the house should take
a deal should take what they can get so
they can help people right away
nancy pelosi seems very certain in
her belief in her strategy that if she
waits long enough
she'll get what she wants from the white
house now the president has been all
over the place but lately
his last landing spot has been that he
wants a big deal and i think he said 1.8
trillion go big or go home
he did so it sounds like she could get a
lot of what she wants
um but it does seem extraordinary that
on the eve of an election
when so many people are hurting when
jerome powell has said err on the side
of doing more rather than less
that congress and the white house can't
come up with the deal now the president
took the blame for pulling the plug on
the negotiations just a couple days ago
and then reversed himself so this seems
to be an opportunity for democrats
which there and it does not seem like
she's taking it um
bill i want to end with you just a few
seconds here we are at a different place
in the coronavirus the
the the numbers are going up as far as
infections
uh some states are seeing
hospitalizations go up but yet there is
very
significant progress on this operation
warp spree speed
and a different sense on in some corners
yes and fatalities are way down but the
bullet and stop the presses is the world
health organization
announced yesterday that lockdowns are
the worst thing to do
and let's not do it thanks a lot world
health organization
now you tell us after 82 trillion
dollars which is the estimate
they put on what's this cost 150 million
mostly children driven into poverty
more deaths than from coronavirus uh
children and
underdeveloped countries because they
lack food water and inoculation
because things have been shut down oh
not a good idea to have a lockdown
wish you'd said that a little earlier
it's been very costly here and around
the world
some of us thought that from the
beginning this should be getting a lot
of attention a lot of attention
and let's hope operation warp street
speed continues to speed
guy i'll catch you next time panel thank
you